hi there it's Kevin Van Ord here
standing in for reviewer Nick Kappa Zoli
to tell you about the early access
release of burrow force
broforce the game introduces you to bro
force the force a huge collection of
human wrecking balls inspired by the
past 30 years of big screen action
terminator indiana jones blade and
MacGyver are all at home here cheering
you on as you mow through baddies with
guns and swords as a randomly chosen
four row you kill your way across
jungles and cities aiming for an exit
point or a boss fight the way you get
there is up to your discretion though
the terrain gets blasted away by your
weaponry the same as any enemy so
tunneling through 20 feet of concrete
with a shotgun is as valid a way to the
levels end as any other it opens up some
interesting strategic possibilities like
shooting the floor out from underneath
an otherwise imposing foe it also makes
for some zany unpredictable runs
especially when you're paired with
trigger-happy teammates who don't give
much thought to blowing up the platform
you're standing on the campaign can be
taken online and there are a few local
multiplayer diversions on offer as well
bros are imprisoned in cages that dot
the levels when you free one you assume
the role of the new bro and the old one
drops away to become a sort of extra
life there's no way to determine what
bro you're freeing meaning the full
roster remains in circulation
each bro has a well-defined role that
makes clever use of their iconic
Arsenal the one that looks like Snake
Plissken uses a sniper rifle the one
that looks like agent J from men in
black uses a noisy cricket that packs a
wallop but flings and backwards with few
exceptions the bros can only hit targets
that are in front of them and at their
exact elevation consequently attacking
an enemy who's located anywhere else
means meeting them on their own turf
sinking or rising to their level in a
very literal sense given the hulked out
characters the mega fonts and the
gratuitous guitars
broforce would seem to have its tongue
planted firmly in cheek
but the satirical boomerang never comes
back around terrorists with dynamite
strapped to their chests run towards you
in inept - aside bombing attempts and
the game doesn't shy away from using
collateral damage as a fireworks display
broforce feels kind of tone-deaf
becoming that which it tries to satirize
at least the fireworks are colorful
layers of stage crumble under apart
under fire setting off chain reactions
that level huge portions of the
environment in seconds at any given
moment 3/4 of the screen is engulfed in
flames collapsing or bleeding you gunned
down the guys in masks and the giant
robots because that's what you do in
games you react instinctively adapt
quickly to the simple controls move ever
to the right leap the bottomless pits
and shoot the red barrels and grin at
all the ensuing chaos all the explosions
can make it easy to lose track of your
fragile bro especially when paired with
an overbearing screen shaking effect and
not all bros are born equal
Indiana Browns flare gun is terribly
ineffective and Robocop's ability to
charge up attacks is wholly out of place
in a game that demands a generous output
of lead but the varied roster and
combustible level design mean that no
two runs through on one of grow forces
stages feels alike and the game's brisk
pace ensures you're always being whisked
away to do something new well hanging
from a helicopter while everything blows
up behind you for no obvious reason
you